okay eric you got this i believe in you
thank you okay so dina
is that my humor so am i white i'm black
right
you're black okay you gotta tell me
you're black okay
you're black okay good luck okay all
right start
three two one
all right i go away the pawn on e4
e5 all right okay so we're playing three
two correct
nine of three i have six six gotta play
the russian in russia
knight takes c5 knight c6
so solid staff time
yeah what is that you obviously don't
watch youtube this is my favorite
i should have i should have
what is what should be the most
intelligent move here i don't think i
can help you
nine takes c6 okay do you take two six
zero whoa
i can't even go do four but i won't
what is that bishop e2 uh bishop c5
short castle
yes crazy totally crazy
[Music]
93 development first
interesting are we going to take the dmc
for this one
it's uh all covered it's still covered i
like it i'll play
everything's a cover remember knight g4
it's because i'm from spotify
uh 9g4 yes wow
he means it it means business i'm just a
crazy person
they're trying to do crazy things
actually makes a lot of sense thank you
now i'm getting worried
it's so peaceful just listening to the
surroundings not having to deal with the
as long as it's your move you can trash
like all you want
i don't like my position isn't there
like a term for this called kubitsing
isn't that what we're doing no
convincing people who are not playing
the game i'm talking about the game yeah
but you're you're kind of half playing
actually
i'm gonna go with a flow what is the
club
there's a river nearby can you jump in
i don't understand it i'm not getting
beated by men
blindfolded it's king safety first
you i'm trying to look into his eyes to
understand
what is he thinking of but i see my eyes
we're still have some reason i cannot
see his eyes
for some reason i really wonder why do
you know i really wonder
i do not really know but yeah we're not
entirely sure this time i cannot read my
opinions
yes okay i'm gonna play queen h4
okay right
um i guess there is only one move here
and it's called h3
okay and i want to do crazy things queen
g3
queen g3 okay oh that's a very lovely
move
thank you i can't see it but i can
appreciate it
what's the time situation you have two
minutes and dean has 56 seconds bishop
takes g4
pawn pawn g4
d4 yeah that's a move
it's getting a little hard
okay bishop bishop takes d4
okay only move 92.
yeah oh no that's cold
a double attack oh you forced me a
little bit
yeah but it's just a little bit on each
just a little bit okay just a little bit
wait there's so many pins in this
position
just do not get yourself pinned too much
before it's too late i might need your
help with that
okay let's play um queen
queen e5 all right
oh my god
queen f6 i'm just protecting myself
knight takes d4 uh queen of four
queen takes that four queen takes four
yep we need three
queen to e5
e5 okay
wait
seconds okay every time i say move you
just okay i just go
i just go got it no hesitation got it
[Music]
rook takes f3 bishop e6
fast
[Music]
time 57 seconds 35
knight f four five let it fight tricky
triggy
i play g6 all right
he's good blindfolded he's so good
queen d4 wow you're good too
thank you what's uh queen take sweet
knight takes 37.
knight takes e6 group
a f-1 rook hf-8
wait it was rook af1 right yes rook f6
c7
dina has seven seconds oh it's equal
material yes
rook
b1 b3
for b2 team d3
rook a2 rook takes a2 e5
yeah rook a5 all right e6
rook e5 oh no
rook d5 check king e4
rook d6
group takes f74
that's insulting there's salt right
there
you get too many
but anyway if this goes on youtube show
some love to dina
vilenkaya uh she has a youtube channel
and twitch channel
i'll leave links below so you can
subscribe and follow
and uh eventually lose next time and
yeah i'm in trouble next time